vamos a la revista de prensa con Marta
Moya Marta Buen día para usted Hola
ancla Buenos días bueno en esta feliz
mañana vamos a comenzar con una noticia
que no lo es tanto en Israel veníamos
anunciando en los noticieros que hoy se
conoció la muerte de un activista
palestino durante una huelga de hambre
tras casi tres meses en prisión mientras
se realizaba esta huelga sí Ángela hemos
destacado una noticia del medel Style
que dice que el palestino o sea el
artista palestino jaderman Ha fallecido
Este martes tras más de casi tres meses
en huelga de hambre 87 días
concretamente esto ya ha generado
represalias por parte de gaza y
Palestina con lanzamiento de cohetes y
hay previstas también huelgas generales
en esos territorios adnan era miembro
del grupo de resistencia de las yihad
islámica y fue detenido el 5 de Febrero
en su Residencial Oasis Jordania ocupada
la familia reza este artículo del
mineralista ya había advertido que
su familiar estaba muriendo y acusó a
Israel no de negligencia por no
trasladarlo a un hospital civil sin
embargo las autoridades hebreas dijeron
que él se había negado a recibir
cualquier tipo de asistencia este
artículo dice además que es el primer
preso palestino que muere a causa de una
huelga de hambre bajo custodia de Israel
desde 1992 el activista ya había sido
detenido en 12 ocasiones a lo largo de
su vida y había pasado cerca de ocho
años en prisión y ya había realizado
otras huelgas de hambre en otros
momentos de otras detenciones en estos
en otros momentos de la historia ya ha
habido otros seis palestinos que han
fallecido también por huelgas de hambre
sobre todo en la década de los 70 ya
principios de los 80 ángelo claro y una
imagen aludiendo a la cuestión humana en
este caso no Así es bueno tras haberse
conocido la noticia también reaccionó el
medio al jazzira que realizó una nota
infográfica sobre todo esta situación si
Ángela y toma los datos al jazira del
grupo de derechos de presos adamer y
sostiene que hasta abril de 2022 por lo
tanto la cifra podría ser mucho más
elevada un año después hay
4.450 palestinos recluidos en cárceles
israelíes en Israel y además en los
territorios ocupados los palestinos
hablan de que son prisioneros de guerra
que luchan contra la ocupación ilegal
israelí de esos 4.450 palestinos en
cárceles israelíes 530 están en cárceles
bajo detención administrativa que es una
suerte de permiso que permite a las
autoridades israelíes no
alertar de los cargos a los reos Y
además que no se celebre un juicio
contra ellos 160 son niños recordemos
que Israel es el único país del mundo
que
juzga a menores en tribunales militares
desde el año 2000 ha juzgado a 12.000
niños y es además la mayoría por lanzar
piedras que delito en Israel castigado
con hasta 20 años de cárcel Angela 32
mujeres
400 o sea 549 están bajo cadena perpetua
y 499 palestinos condenados en Israel
cumplen una pena de más de 20 años de
prisión Bueno pues es esta cuestión
monstruosa de que siempre ponen duda la
lucha por la democracia que enarbola la
propia Israel vamos a cambiar de tema
con otra huelga pero definitivamente
este tema va para el otro lado no y son
los libretistas de Hollywood hoy inicia
el paro de estos guionistas que exigen
mejores condiciones laborales y esto
potencialmente puede ser una grave
crisis para esta gran Industria del cine
y la televisión Así es Ángela han pasado
16 años desde la última huelga de
guionistas en Hollywood hasta hoy este
artículo de la agencia associated
Express que hemos destacado Comenta los
puntos clave que han llevado a esta
huelga de guionistas de cine y de
televisión que ha empezado Esta media
noche a la hora del Pacífico de Estados
Unidos y que desde ya se van a ver sus
consecuencias en la parrilla televisiva
todo esto enfrenta a los guionistas de
cine de televisión y a los sindicatos
que lo respaldan contra la alianza de
productores de cine y televisión que
representa a Hollywood no cada tres años
estas dos partes negocian renegocian
Mejor dicho sus contratos y los puntos
en disputa de esta última negociación
que ha llevado finalmente a la huelga
son Por una parte el pago a los
guionistas por la transmisión de los
programas Por otra parte la llegada del
streaming que ha reducido a los al
número de guionistas en un tercio y por
otra parte la falta de un calendario
estacional que regule la transmisión de
estos programas
asociated sostiene que no sería loco
pensar que incluso después de haberse
concluido el contrato y que esto haya
motivado la huelga se pudiera llegar a
un acuerdo entre las partes como ya
ocurrió en 2017 y por otra parte hemos
de estar hemos destacado un artículo del
New York que dice que si el paro sigue
adelante esto se va a notar ya
definitivamente esta misma noche en la
parrilla estadounidense con
la salida de la parrilla de programas
nocturnos como detona show de Jimmy
fallon o el Live de Jimmy kimmel no
porque al final son programas que
utilizan a guionistas a diario en 2007
la última huelga estos programas dejaron
de estar al aire dos meses además
sostiene el New York Times que otros
programas que se podrían ver afectados
son por ejemplo las novelas diarias y si
la huelgas Ya sé alargará en los meses
veríamos afecciones también tanto en las
series de streaming como en las
películas Aunque estos efectos Se
podrían ver más a largo plazo y a
finales de año bueno es que uno cree que
estos salen todos Pues sí muy natural y
sin preparación y no hay un montón de
gente trabajando para que personas como
usted y como yo podamos estar aquí
conversando tan tranquilamente vamos a
hacer el cierre en España Marta esta
última semana ha estado llena de
polémica por la publicación del capítulo
de un libro que
tiene que el rey emérito tiene una hija
secreta en qué va esta trampa Así es
Ángela y nos referimos a un artículo del
confidencial que pre publicaba un
capítulo del libro titulado Kim corp el
Imperio nunca ha contado de Juan Carlos
I Que firma los periodistas José María
olmo y David Fernández en este capítulo
del libro sostienen que el rey emérito
Juan Carlos I tiene una hija secreta que
nació de una relación extramatrimonial
con una aristócrata europea a finales de
los 70 principios de los 80 la mujer se
llama Alejandra tiene un hijo está
casada y nunca reclamó derechos
sucesorios además ignoró o sea creció
ignorando Quién era su padre cuando lo
supo prefirió mantenerse al margen desde
hace años toda la familia real sabe de
la existencia de esta persona pero el
rey quiso ocultárselo cuando era joven
ahora Rey Felipe por miedo a que su hijo
se enamorara de esta mujer y sin saber
que eran familia no y toda esta
información está corroborada por
varias fuentes que ambos periodistas
dicen tener para publicar este libro
Pues hay aquí un nuevo escándalo de otra
monarquía cada vez más deslegitimada
gracias a usted Marta gracias Ángela